pour commencer on prend donc la
direction de londres où les partisans de
julian assange sont nombreux devant la
haute cour de justice à la justice
britannique doit statuer sur la demande
en appel d'extradition du fondateur de
wikileaks elle avait rejeté en janvier
une première requête on retrouve notre
envoyé spécial katia technique
katia bonjour quelle est l'atmosphère
sur place
et goûter une atmosphère avec évidemment
beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup de colère
mais aussi de l'espoir un concert vient
de se dérouler ici appelant évidemment à
libérer julian assange à s'opposer à
l'extradition appelant également à la
liberté de presse est à l'arrêt à des
crimes de guerre donc 300 personnes ici
et puis beaucoup de pancartes et
beaucoup de rubans aussi des rubans
jaunes sur lesquelles sont inscrits les
noms des personnes qui n'ont pas pu se
rendre ici donc devant la revel
courneuve justice pendant l'audience
d'extradition en appel alors qu'est ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de ce
tribunal et bien tout simplement
le représentant américain avant ses
arguments ce moment même à l'audience a
commencé à 10h30 heure locale alors par
exemple les américains ont pu faire cet
appel en contestant l'expertisé
psychiatrique qui était favorable à
julian assange disant qu'il était
déprimé et désorienté or cette expertise
a été remise en cause parce que elle
aurait dissimulé le fait que julian
assange avait une compagne et deux
enfants hors bon ça ne s'annule pas
évidemment sur cette dépression ses
tendances suicidaires mais en tout cas
voilà les arguments américains james
lewis le représentant a appuyé sur
plusieurs points diplomatiques affirmant
que la grande bretagne n'avait jamais eu
plaindre durant la longue coopération
avec les américains et que les états
unis donneraient des assurances que
julian assange ne serait pas mise à
l'isolément et qu'il effectuerait sa
peine ou en australie et non pas aux
états unis ont des garanties évidemment
qui sont aujourd'hui bien sûr contestée
par les personnes qui sont là devant le
tribunal sa compagne celle à maurice est
venue également son père on les écoute
nous n'abandonnons pas
il n'est pas au meilleur de sa forme
mais il est prêt à se défendre il montre
sa volonté de combattre c'est un défi
qui dure depuis douze ans
c'est une prison de sécurité maximale
avec de petites cellules
il peut avoir accès à un téléphone s'ils
le demandent donc bien sûr il est en
contact avec sa famille
autre chose à savoir qui inquiète
beaucoup ici de julian assange n'a pas
été autorisée à assister à sa propre
audience concernant son extradition à
cause d'une hotte de z de médicaments
qui lui a été donné dans sept ans un peu
inquiétant pour tous les soutiens ici et
donc nous nous tiendrons au courant du
progrès cette audience au cours de
l'après midi merci beaucoup à vous
qu'elle tient technique pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de la haute cour de
justice britannique